there are some really interesting posts
on the david pakman show subreddit that
i wanted to call your attention to
this morning of course you can join the
discussion at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t we now have a nearly 23 000
if you can imagine it i remember when
the subreddit was
uh teeny tiny we now have almost 23
000 of our viewers and listeners
participating there find it
at davidpakman.com reddit a user
named texas mickey posted
call me an optimist but i think david is
wrong about the number of trumpists in
the country
i've heard him say that even if biden
wins
this country will still need to grapple
with 60 million trumpists who voted for
him
i won't dispute that trumpus will be a
problem for this country long after
trump is out of office however
i don't believe that even most
republican voters are
trumpists i think we underestimate the
number of people who just vote for
whoever has a big
r next to their name on the ballot and
move on with their lives they're not die
hards
they're loyal voters who don't really
care about policy they couldn't tell you
what trump has done well or poorly they
couldn't tell you how biden differs from
trump in any meaningful way
they just vote the party line every four
years
i'm not saying the trumpist ideology
isn't something to be taken as a serious
threat
i only mean that i think it's a smaller
sect within the party
well you know the oftentimes when we
talk about
radical islam you will hear these
sort of um concentric circles
of nominal the nominal muslim world
which is a billion people
and then within that these subsequently
smaller and smaller groups and you could
do this for any population you could do
it with
christian extremists you could do it
with jewish extremists these smaller and
smaller circles
you're right that if you start with 65
million people who
might vote for donald trump in november
not all 65
are the problematic radical trumpists
that's for sure
but certainly the 65 million are people
who decided to go along with it
regardless and that's bad enough
in a lot of ways you can then look at
smaller numbers so of the 65 million
you have some portion who almost voted
for biden but went with the republican
because of their historically republican
they might be the least defensive of the
group
then you've got people who actually like
what donald trump presents
in terms of what he uh uh says he will
do policy wise but also more his idea of
constantly trying to trigger the left
and you like that that might be
you know 80 and then you've got these
concentric circles that's true
the problem is that
when we think about the future of the
country
it is worse if you are a die-hard
trumpist
than just a lifelong republic republican
who checks the box for republicans
that's true
but it's still a total of 65 million
people
who voted for it and if given the
opportunity might vote for it again so
while you're right that 65 million is
not
the number of you know the crazy people
with the guns that we're seeing at
protests
that's true 65 million is still the
number of people who if given the
opportunity would probably do it again
and that's why it's extraordinarily
dangerous another post
from a user on the subreddit posted
an article about doctors who are alarmed
that the usfda is floating emergency use
of a coronavirus vaccine potentially
bypassing some of the trials
i predicted that this was going to
happen i told you guys months ago that
it was going to happen i wasn't the only
person saying it
it's not a pat on the back it's that it
was so obvious that this was going to
happen and yes
even people who are in favor of vaccines
are writing to me worried that using
emergency use authorization mechanisms
to push a vaccine out for likely
political benefit by donald trump
is something we should be concerned
about and that's what i'm going to talk
about next i'm glad that it's on
people's radars
remember you can join the discussion on
the subreddit at davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video